♪ ♪
>> Sean: JOE BIDEN TODAY
INVITED POLICE OFFICIALS FROM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO THE
WHITE HOUSE TO DISCUSS SURGING
CRIME IN CITY AFTER CITY.
MOST OF THEM CITIES THAT ARE RUN
BY DEMOCRATS FOR DECADES, STATES
RUN BY DEMOCRATS FOR DECADES,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE REFUSES TO TAKE ANY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR ROLE IN
SPEWING THE DEFUND POLICE AGENDA
AND THEIR ROLE IN MAKING
COMMUNITIES LESS SAFE, LESS
SECURE, MORE VIOLENT.
FOR EXAMPLE, WASHINGTON, D.C.,
MARKED A GRIM MILESTONE OVER
THIS PAST WEEKEND AFTER IT HIT
100 HOMICIDES BY JULY THE 10TH.
THAT'S THE EARLIEST A CITY HAS
HIT THAT NUMBER SENSE, GET THIS,
2003.
CHICAGO, 11 KILLED, 35 WOUNDED,
VIOLENCE OVER THE WEEKEND.
IN OTHER WORDS, A TYPICAL
WEEKEND IN THE WINDY CITY.
DO YOU KNOW ANY OF THE NAMES OF
ANY OF THE PEOPLE THAT WERE SHOT
AND SHOT AND KILLED THIS WEEKEND
IN CHICAGO?
I DOUBT IT.
WHY?
BECAUSE THE LEFT IN HIS COUNTRY
AS WE HAVE POINTED OUT FOR YEARS
ON THIS SHOW ONLY SEEMS TO CARE
ABOUT THE LIVES OF PEOPLE KILLED
WHEN THEY CAN THEN USE THEIR
DEATH TO POLITICIZE AN ISSUE.
IS THE REAL SLOGAN FOR DEMOCRATS
BLACK LIVES MATTER ONLY WHEN WE
CAN POLITICIZE IT?
WHERE IS MAYOR LORI WILL
LIGHTWEIGHT?
WHERE IS THE ACCOUNT BILLING FOR
THESE FAR LEFT FAILURES?
NEW YORK CITY THIS WEEKEND, A
13-YEAR-OLD, 19-YEAR-OLD, THEY
WERE KILLED, SEVEN OTHERS
INJURED IN SIX SHOOTINGS OVER 14
HOURS ACROSS THE CITY OF
NEW YORK.
UNFORTUNATELY, RATHER THAN
BLUNTLY ACKNOWLEDGE THE ROLE
THAT DEMOCRATS ANTI-POLICE
DEFUNDING POLICIES ARE CAUSING
AND FUELING THIS CRIME SURGE,
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE FOR MAYOR,
WELL, HIS NAME IS ERIC ADAMS,
THE DEMOCRAT PRAISING BIDEN'S
COMMITMENT TO "REDEFINE THE
ECOSYSTEM OF PUBLIC SAFETY,"
WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
THANKFULLY THERE IS INDEPENDENT
REPUBLICAN NAMED CURTIS WHO IS
RUNNING ON REFUNDING THE POLICE
AND BRING BACK THE POLICIES THAT
WORKED UNDER RUDY GIULIANI.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
DEMOCRAT.
OF >> WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO
RESPOND TO SYMPTOMS.
IT'S TIME TO RESPOND TO THE
UNDERLYING CAUSES OF VIOLENCE IN
OUR CITIES.
OF THIS IS MAKING IT CLEAR HE'S
GOING TO REDEFINE THE ECOSYSTEM
OF PUBLIC SAFETY AND THAT
INCLUDES A DEFINED ROLE OF
POLICE, SCHOOLS, FAMILIES,
RESOURCES, EMPLOYMENT.
THIS IS WHERE WE NEED TO GO AS A
COUNTRY.
>> Sean: FIRST, LET'S BE
HONEST, THIS PRESIDENT MAKES
NOTHING CLEAR.
ONE ACTIVIST IN THE BRONX AND
NEW YORK'S SAID THESE
COMMUNITIES NEED HELP I NEED TO
REDUCE THE TENSION BETWEEN
OFFICERS AND THE COMMUNITY.
PUSHING BACK AGAINST THE DEFUND
AGENDA.
HERE TO EXPLAIN MORE IS
COMMUNITY ACTIVIST MELODY WITH
US ALONG TO AS LONG AS LEO 20
TERRELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
I WAS GLAD YOU SAID WHAT YOU
SAID.
THEY CAUGHT A BILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE NEW YORK POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
WE NOW ARE SHATTERING LAST
YEAR'S RECORD IN TERMS OF
VIOLENCE AND MURDERS, INJURIES
TO COPS AND DEATHS, ET CETERA.
DEFUND, DISMANTLE, REIMAGINE.
I DON'T KNOW, WHY DON'T WE GO
BACK TO WHAT BROUGHT THE MURDER
RATE FROM NEARLY 3,000 TO 300
AND THAT IS STOP AND FRISK AND
DEFUNDING THE POLICE --
REFUNDING THE POLICE, WHAT YOU
THINK?
>> I CAN DEFINITELY SAY I AGREE
WITH WHAT YOU JUST STATED.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
KEEP PUBLIC SAFETY NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY IN NEW YORK CITY.
THE CRIME RATE HAS SPIKED.
AND I THINK IT'S TIME FOR A
MAYOR THAT IS WILLING TO ENSURE
THAT NYPD IS FOND OF THE CORRECT
WAY WHERE THEY ARE COMFORTABLE
TO COME ON AND DO THEIR JOB
BECAUSE THEIR JOBS ARE
DIFFICULT.
THEY COME OUT EVERY DAY AND RISK
THEIR LIVES AND I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE NEED TO
PAY ATTENTION TO.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK, ARE YOU
UNDER FIRE FOR THE STATEMENTS
THAT YOU'RE MAKING BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO SAVE LIVES AND YOU WANT
STRONG POLICING?
>> AT THIS MOMENT, SEAN, I'M NOT
UNDER FIRE.
I HAVE A GREAT CONNECTION WITH
THE COMMUNITY, I WORK WITH
MOTHERS THAT LOSE THEIR KIDS
AFFECTED BY DONE GANG AND STREET
VIOLENCE.
AT THIS POINT I HAVE THE SUPPORT
OF THE MOTHERS AND LOCAL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY.
>> Sean: I WILL TAKE THE
SUPPORT OF MOMS.
WE ALL LOVE OUR CHILDREN, DON'T
WE, WHO WANT THEM TO BE -- WHO
WANT LAW AND ORDER, SAFETY AND
SECURITY, SO EVERY CHILD IN
AMERICA CAN ACTUALLY PURSUE
HAPPINESS.
WITHOUT IT, YOU CAN'T.
LEO 20 TERRELL, BIG NEWS
TONIGHT, LARRY ELDER 1.0
APPARENTLY HAS ANNOUNCED HE'S
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR.
ARE YOU GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
OUR FRIEND?
>> I WILL BE PROVIDING -- AS I
CAN.
I WILL BE PROVIDING AS MUCH
SUPPORT AS I CAN.
WITH MY CURRENT DUTY.
>> Sean: OKAY.
YOU CAN SPEAK OUT ON THIS SHOW,
LEO, THERE'S NO RULES HERE.
YOU CAN SAY WHAT'S ON YOUR MIND.
>> YES.
IF >> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT
THIS, ANOTHER WEEKEND, MORE
VIOLENCE AND THIS IS ALL NOISE
TO ME, THIS REIMAGINING STUFF,
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN SAID HE WOULD
REALLOCATE FUNDS FROM AWAY FROM
THE POLICE.
WE KNOW THAT HE DIDN'T MENTION
IT ALL LAST SUMMER WHEN THE
RIOTS WERE GOING ON.
WE KNOW THE KAMALA HARRIS, YOU
KNOW, PROMOTED A BAIL FUND SO
RIDERS COULD BACK ON THE STREETS
AND BACK TO THE ACTIVITIES AND
ROCKS AND BOTTLES, ET CETERA.
AND STARTING FIRES AND
EVERYTHING ELSE WE SAW.
>> LET ME BE AS CLEAR AS I CAN,
THAT MEETING, THAT WAS A DOG AND
PONY SHOW.
NOTHING WAS DONE THERE.
TALK ABOUT GUN CONTROL, GUN
RIGHTS, NO.
IT IS CRIME ALLOWED BY DEMOCRATS
AND DEMOCRATIC CITIES.
BAD NEWS FOR NEW YORKERS.
ERIC ADAMS, HE WENT TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., TO KISS THE
RING OF JOE BIDEN.
UNTIL HE CRITICIZED AOC -- UNTIL
HE CRITICIZED -- UNTIL HE
ARTICULATES HIS POSITION
SEPARATE FROM THE PROGRESSIVE
LEFT, HE'S JUST LIKE
DE BLASIO, SO HE'S NEVER GOING
TO CHANGE.
HE GOT EXCITED GOING TO THE
WHITE HOUSE AND KISSING
JOE BIDEN'S REIGN.
THE ISSUE ABOUT CRIME IS GOING
TO BE AN ISSUE FOR 2022 AND THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE LOST THAT ISSUE
AND I REALLY FEEL SORRY BECAUSE
HONESTLY SHE'S NOT GETTING ANY
SUPPORT FROM THE LAWMAKERS IN
NEW YORK CITY.
>> Sean: WE ARE GOING TO KEEP
OUR EYE ON THIS --
>> I'M OPTIMISTIC AND I'M OKAY
WITH THAT BECAUSE SOMETIMES YOU
HAVE TO FIGHT FOR CHANGE.
THE LOCAL POLITICIANS ARE VERY
AWARE OF HOW I FEEL AND THEY
SEEM TO SCATTER WHEN I GIVE
STATEMENTS BUT THEY ARE
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPORTANCE OF
NYPD, BECAUSE I DEFTLY GO TO
DIFFERENT -- GAP.
>> Sean: I HOPE YOU STAY
ACTIVE AND I HOPE YOUR VOICE IS
LOUD, BECAUSE LIVES NEED TO BE
SAVED.
THIS IS OUR NATIONAL TREASURE,
THESE ARE OUR KIDS.
THIS IS OUR AMERICAN FAMILY.
LIVES ARE LOST EVERY WEEK AND
BURIED WE CAN PREDICT EVERY WEE